I want to jump to this story from the
Daily Mail New York teacher manipulated
fifth grade student into changing gender
without parents consent which drove her
to consider suicide lawsuit claims it
was only after the girl nine Drew
suicidal images that her parents found
out teacher Deborah rosenquist was
calling her Leo and using he him
pronouns superintendent Jennifer J Quinn
and Terryville Road Elementary School
principal Anna Marie V skip
admitted they knew about rosenquist's
antics so we'll just uh look at this I
mean just one weird whoa I'm so
surprised of my lungs aren't you
surprised that that's what she looks
like you guys but think about this there
there is a there is a little girl who
knows and believes she is a little girl
and the teacher keeps saying no you're a
boy and your name is Leo causing such
distress that the nine-year-old
contemplated suicide
it's almost like these people are
demonic and I said that figuratively not
literally I don't believe in demons I
just don't think well I guess you can
call some things demons I just don't
think adults should have secrets with a
nine-year-old from their parents right
the fact that she's not saying like hey
your kid is expressing some confusion
about their gender or whatever like if
that happened in your classroom go
immediately to their parents you're an
adult you shouldn't have secrets with
children 100
it's so obvious I just don't understand
like why is this even a question and
then this idea that like oh well their
parents wouldn't be accepting well maybe
it's because they're nine and you're a
stranger and you don't have any right to
tell a kid what their what you know like
you said if it will be accepting or not
that is for the family they have
whatever beliefs they have that is for
the child and the parent but today
children have become the vehicles and
the medium for people to project their
social and political views onto and then
that way they can use kids in any
example and say well what about the kids
if you don't affirm their gender then
they're going to commit suicide if you
don't let me take them to a drag show
then they're going to commit suicide and
it's like no no that is for the parent
to decide you do not get a relationship
with that kid outside of what the parent
is doing and that is the definition of
grooming you always get these claims I
get them all the time oh we're not
groomers you're calling everyone a
groomer if you're doing anything to lead
a child down a path that goes against
what the parent is teaching you are
grooming them whether it's sexual
political whatever it is that is the
definition of Grooming
well and then also how else would we
bring to these hearings right I remember
listening to public radio in West
Virginia when they had one of their uh
like can you give hormones to underage
children and they're like just listen to
this Brave testimony from a 12 year old
who identifies as transgender you want
to be like this person is 12. they
shouldn't be here why are they the
political tool of essentially the
pharmaceutical industry and their messed
up parents and teachers like this is
crazy somebody posted uh I think in like
Massachusetts they have an
anti-sterilization law that says that
any doctor that performs a medical
procedure that sterilizes a child is
guilty of a felony I think it was
Massachusetts and they're just like how
come not this is not being prosecuted
like how come not going after people who
are doing this that seems like one of
the most obvious things that that you
can imagine like if a doctor performs a
a a surgery or whatever on a child
without the parents uh consent uh they
must be they even need to them there are
some high schools in California that
have planned parenthoods attach them or
they're like on campus and they'll offer
you know referrals for birth control
they can't prescribe there but they'll
also offer referrals for hormone therapy
or any kind of like transgender issue
may have
why why would you not want to be
involved in what's going on with your
minor right I understand if that
person's 18 they're an adult and that's
a different argument but School
shouldn't be facilitating private
conversations with adults without the
parents presence that seems so obvious
and yet we just abandoned this principle
all the time I mean yeah you're right
it's obvious well they're introducing a
bill in Florida right now that would
make businesses who offer uh payment for
gender gender affirming care to their
employees to be responsible for the D
transition cost if there is regret this
was a bill that was introduced I think a
couple weeks ago and it'll be
interesting to see how that plays out
because I can imagine that businesses
are going to say wait hold on if they
regret this if I offer them surgery they
do something that they regret and I will
be liable for their detransition
hormones or surgery whatever I may not
want to take that risk and it'll be
really interesting to see how businesses
respond to this
I just think that they'll they'll say
yeah we'll do that because we don't
think that many people will uh will
detransition I think that we as a
society not we in this room but
generally people are not willing to
acknowledge the risks that are like
you're bringing up uh sterility
sterilization laws in Massachusetts
they're not enforcing it because they're
not saying it's definitely for sure
going to sterilize you there's a chance
it might I mean the studies are pretty
clear on what the consequences of some
of these uh interventionists either
hormonal surgical treatments are for
people who identify as transgender but
there's enough gray area where they're
skating by saying like well but maybe
it's helping because they're depressed
or whatever else like this is going to
be it's going to get worse before it
gets better right because the data is
living in this gray area even though
Common Sense tells us one thing we have
enough uh ambiguity in the Medical
Science to deny it well if there's
anything that made me believe in
possession by demons it's stuff like
this like the weird cult-like behavior
that we've seen from the woke left the
inability to process information and the
rejection of fact now maybe it's not
demons it's just that some people can
get put in a cult-like trance but it
sure does feel like demonic possessions
it's not it's not Supernatural but it's
probably what people were describing
when they started calling people
demonically possessed like the behaviors
were the same when like as they were
trying to figure these things out you
might call them psychotic nowadays or
whatever but like when you say evil
there are behaviors that people can
engage in that will qualify them as evil
because they fit the definition the word
has a definition if you engage in these
activities you are evil there are things
that you can do that are demonic that
qualify as a definition that doesn't
mean that there's actually like
Supernatural like 10th Dimension demons
living
like there were you know like
inter-dimensional beings and I don't
mean like demons from other dimensions I
mean demons in between the dimensions
you know like in between realities and
the twisting now that the demons come
out you know they do their thing I call
it what you want I think it's semantics
but you know if there was a word for it
uh grooming miners into the radical left
gender ideology that has them chemically
castrate and generally mutilate
themselves evil that would be it evil
yeah
I feel like sad because they just prey
on parents who are scared right if I
told you your kid is suicidal and if you
don't do this one thing they'll die I
mean there are a lot of parents who
would be like I'll do anything to keep
my kid alive the issue is the kids are
suicidal because of the teachers exactly
that's what they say listen to how
predatory this is they say to the
parents would you rather have a boy
daughter or a dead daughter
imagine as a parent's daughter a
translator yeah when they're going in
for these these gender surgeries and
their consultations they tell the
parents would you rather have a boy
that's a girl or would you have it would
you rather have a dead daughter think
about that as a parent think about a
medical professional that you should
have some trust in saying you either
have to medically chemically castrate
your child and give them these these
drugs or they will kill themselves that
is predatory and lay on top of that well
and you didn't know they were going
through this and the teacher had to tell
you which means your kid doesn't feel
comfortable with you like it's just
Guilt Trip after abusive guilt trip I
feel sad experience hopefully have
enough common sense not to do this I
don't feel bad for the parents who are
like no this is a good idea let me bring
my child to political rallies and prop
them up as a representation of what a
good woke parent I am but I do think
that there is at some core you know I
think a lot of parents are scared and
they want to do the right thing and I
think the fact that this industry is
preying on this because that's what it
is it's an industry is just disgusting
and I I can't believe that this wouldn't
be be an obvious point where we unite as
a culture and say this is bad but
apparently we can't which is
mind-boggling it is an industry you
trans a child you have a patient for
life and that's a lot of money yes
there's there's a lot of things that are
actually lining up that that are have a
certain Synergy so you've got the
financial incentive from hospitals
you've got the ideologically possessed
uh people that are looking to actually
mess up Society they want their
ideological and want a revolution you
undermine the structure of the family
exactly exactly and then you've also got
a lot of a lot of your default Democrats
right your your knee-jerk I want to vote
to be nice people which is the majority
of the Democrat Party right the the
people that are actually
the thought leaders are are the ones
that are probably you know the the
committed leftists your average foot
soldier for lack of a better term is a
is a soccer mom that just wants to do
what's right for her kids and wants to
like not make waves at the PTA meeting
too much because she wants everyone to
get along because they might bump into
each other at the Starbucks on Tuesday
you know it's it's that stuff really has
an effect on people so the motivation or
the the incentive doesn't have to be
some cabal that's handing out uh you
know cue drops or whatever it it can be
just the common uh General narrative
that people are believing and people
trying to do what they think is the
right thing yeah I think it's terrible
to put children at the center of this
and I think that's why the left is so
willing to do it right because I think
there are so many people who are
compassionate they realize that children
don't aren't able to advocate for
themselves fully and they are ultimately
um you know a lot of our law looks at
them as basically obsessions of their
parents they are in a lot of respect
even though they have they are people
with rights and they know that basically
you get a two for one voter right so if
you get the parents support you and the
kid goes through it they're probably
also going to support your cause it's
it's Mass recruiting people to your side
of the line and that's terrifying
because it has intense real consequences
for those involved you know that saying
Missouri loves company
laughs
yeah I've heard something like that yeah
might have been a little different it is
kind of weird that when people are are
living in a self-induced induced I'm
just thinking about it I want you to
live in it as well you know what I mean
they the crabs in a bucket crabs in a
barrel they don't want you getting out
they want you to suffer if they have to
suffer yeah well have you ever met like
have you ever had a friend that they
base their entire personality around
problems that they have and them like
these are problems that are so fixable
they would be so easy to fix but they
get more out of having the problem and
the attention that they receive from it
than they would if they just fix the
problem and you have these you have
these groups that they they bond over
their problems and then it's like when
people fix them and they leave the group
they're they're demonized right they're
so it's weird and that's what you're
seeing I think on a societal scale that
when you have a victim class it's easy
to control it's easy to feel good about
yourself there's no self-accountability
there's no self-work that you have to do
if you're a victim then you will always
have someone to blame and you will never
have to fix your problems yeah I
remember people that are so negative
that just complain about everything and
that person's not doing the right thing
by them or whatever else and you walk
away feeling negative and you just don't
want to hang out with them again for a
while and I think we're seeing this on a
mass scale right so if you're a young
person in society and all of your
friends are upset about something and
then you open Twitter and everything's
everyone's complaining and fighting and
then you look at the news and everything
is bad like how could you not start to
feel just totally black pilled thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time